[Musique]
en direct de montréal cette entame
canada aujourd'hui 6 mars 2020 ici en
studio ya beaucoup de monde mais aussi
de l'autre côté de la fenêtre de
réalisation il y en a aussi
il ya marc andré deschamps pier dutil et
pierre luc lahaye
bien sûr le côté technique de l'émission
maintenant pour ce qui est du côté de
l'intelligence de la connaissance
c'est pas garantie via trois personnes
ici monsieur qui vont tenter de remplir
le défi relevé le défi alors stéphane
parent ici au microphone bientôt à la
télévision de les voir ça s'en vient ça
s'enlève voilà bonjour tout le monde
et puis on à ismaël qui est avec nous
bonjour israël jean-marie ça risque est
de retour ça fait un tout le temps qu'on
vous appelle pas invité alors seule
représentante de la gente féminine c'est
fantastique vous en voirie sur ce que
celle 8 mars dimanche quand même j'avais
fait que j'allais pas dire que je
l'avais oublié parce que moi je vis au
jour le jour j'atteins le jour pour me
faire à quel âge faut les mettre au
parfum de la situation savait pas déjà
vous restez au goût du jour quand même
dimanche j'avais truc c'est de savoir
jouer des jeunes et tout ça aurait coûté
aujourd'hui vous n'avez encore une fois
aucune idée du sujet dont on va traiter
ensemble
non c'est une bonne chose ça vous permet
comme ça de jouer le jeu des cinq images
avec moi et ça donne une avance à
stéphane non mais j'ai je sais tout
alors je besoin d'être c'est à nous
d'apprendre et vous à la maison
également ou au bureau dans l'avion
regarder ça avec nous c'est cinq images
vous me dites tous quel est le sujet
aujourd'hui je veux que ça soit précis
parce que vous pourriez le me donner
quelques approximations mais je veux que
ce soit pressions orientées cinq images
voici la première image
voici en tout cas c'est pas comme tam
canada non a alors on voit monsieur
champagne qui est monsieur champagne
ministre des affaires étrangères bien
décrit et l'on voit derrière ministre
navires us way est certainement question
du corps aujourd'hui mais il va être
question des relations c'est sûr mais
encore économie le commerce oui parce
que le commerce va être touché et voici
vraiment le fond tourisme peut-être non
ok d'accord
lisez-le parce qu'on pas tous cas chez
vous pour at elle vraiment se relever
économiquement et politiquement de la
crise du coronavirus oui on va aussi
parler de l'asie a pas seulement la
chine qui est affecté par cette
situation et à l'économie mondiale il ya
le canada les relations avec la chine
quelles sont améliorées il ya des soucis
au niveau 2 du tourisme parce que les
chinois représentent 7% environ 7% du
marché canadien au niveau de tous les
milliards de dollars c'est de l'argent
il ya peut-être d'autres pays qui vont
décider de ne plus voyager ou de soins
d'autres pays
ça s'est pas mal débrouillé en sont
embrouillées semences moment mais on va
s'intéresser à la perception qu'on a
actuellement de la chine et de ce que ça
pourrait signifier pour l'avenir et
beaucoup de choses qui se dit qu'ils se
racontent dans les grands médias les
médias sérieux qui ne pensent qu'ils
réfléchissent à roland terme on va voir
un spécialiste du long terme de
l'analyse avec nous dans un destin
et puis pour le moment de goûter en
studio oui moi avant de laisser les
spécialistes s'exprimer pour vérifier
les connaissances
c'est comme un permis de parler permis
de conduire ce volet alors on part le
premier jeu premier tour 20 boules à
perdre y en a cent au total la perte par
émission c'est un véritable délice quand
il les conserve bien sûr on a fait le
général va que quand elle et chantal est
avec nous elle est souvent désignée ring
c'est vrai on regarde la première
question ensemble s'est assis au fond
c'est très simple vous allez voir vous
en même temps la question est très
simple la réponse ou si je pense si vous
suivez l'actualité à quel moment
l'épidémie at-elle commencé dans la
ville de wimereux
est-ce que c'est au début du mois de
novembre est-ce que c'est au début du
mois de janvier
est-ce que c'est au début du mois de
décembre où aucune de ces réponses à
quel moment
est-ce que l'épidémie a commencé dans la
ville je dirai au début du mois de
janvier
au début du mois de janvier d'accord
mais moi j'hésite entre eux
non je vais dire des bises mois de
décembre début du mois de décembre pour
maryse d'accord c'est normalement on a
fait choix des contrats qui vote qui
parle de 59 à 0 ok on n'a pas besoin
aujourd'hui vous avez répondu très
rapidement à dakar avons nous répondu
vous voulez la bonne réponse est non
mais je les vrd j'ai peut-être aucune ne
se peuvent aussi contribuer ou trois a
baissé
ça a commencé au milieu de voir à quel
moment l'épidémie at-elle commencé dans
la ville de huy b on regarde sans semble
la bonne réponse
elle a commencé à wasmes parce que vous
laissez la pression statique et pensait
attention chevalier blanc
ouais ok alors au mois de décembre
c'était au mois deux mois mois de
novembre alors oui j'allais ajouter
l'astérix mais connaissant tous j'ai des
fois pas besoin d'être mémoire voilà
donc très sérieusement la région
administrative soit exactement ce que je
voulais vous faire sourire un peu pour
commencer parce que lille et lui faire
mal paraître
non on apprend on apprend parce que je
pense que tout ce qui vient de
l'émission ça qu'il faut faire attention
à la comment la question est écrit tout
à fait si vous oubliez ça c'est oublier
l'essentiel et 7 juin s'est assurée que
vous aurez 0 à l'examen et quelle est la
bonne prononciation pour vient
le clemi allez on vous écoute non je ne
pense pas aux mains de nos collègues de
la section peut-être probable écoutez je
vous êtes prêts pour les choses très
sérieuses maintenant des autres
enregistraient sérieuse parce que vous
avez vu ce qui se passe à la bourse
depuis un bout de temps du jour ça monte
des jours ça baisse tout le monde est
inquiète et pas seulement aux états unis
mais aussi au canada la bourse
canadienne ya des préoccupations c'est
laisser le résultat de tout ce qui se
passe de tout ce qui se dit de toutes
les informations qu'on partage et puis
c'est très instable ouais ça monte une
journée sarah dessaint savamment parce
qu'au fond de l'affairé on ne sait pas
ce que savent signifie vraiment cette
épidémie si ça se transforme en pandémie
en combien de morts est ce que la
contagion est plus sévère vraiment qu
une crypte très sévère par exemple
ok les canalisations préfère me dire bon
alors beaucoup beaucoup de questions et
beaucoup de choses sans réponse pour le
moment
une chose est sûre pendant qu'on parle
beaucoup de nous je passe d'avoir marqué
depuis deux semaines d'enfer
certainement dû remarquer qu'on parle
que du canada coup ce qu'ils pensent aux
états unis en italie
on a tout à fait perdu là de vue moi
j'ai eu l'impression d'avoir fait ce
bond ce qui se passe en chine et les
gains importants qui ont été réalisés en
chine depuis quelques semaines la chute
du nombre de personnes infectées setteur
pourra pas parler de ça c'est sûr mais
il ya des choses très intéressantes qui
se produisent et on a un peu perdu de
vue dans toutes ces histoires là pour
nous en parler pour essayer d'évaluer
avec nous comment la chine pourrait se
tirer d'affaires à quoi ça ressemble une
sortie de crise pour la chaîne en ce
moment et aussi pour l'asie qui est
affecté par tout ça et bien on a un
invité de marque avec nous il s'agit de
serge granger qui est à l'université de
sherbrooke professeur granger qui nous
est spécieuse un politique appliquée et
puis vous connaissez l'asie très très
bien vous avez écrit un ouvrage récent
sur sur les relations sur ce monde là
peu connus très souvent de nous les
canadiens
oui j'ai d'appel l'asie du sud est à la
croisée des puissances au mois de mars
passé alors fattouche bien sûr l'asie du
sud-est et tous les grands pays sont au
tour en l'occurrence bien sûr la chine
l'inde le japon et cetera donc beaucoup
de choses qui se produit géopolitique
pas
bien sûr il ya des aspects économiques à
cette histoire qui va nous intéresser
aujourd'hui j'aime ça qu'on garde ça
pour être plus tard vrai qu'on aborde la
question dans lesquelles vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup d'informations c'est
l'aspect disons du pouvoir politique
chinois on va commencer par ça parce que
dans le jeu pensé dans new york times
martin on a publié des renseignement lé
fait que les il ya des responsables
chinois qui commence à dire non ce virus
ne venait pas de chez nous ça vient
d'ailleurs on sent là le spin doctor qui
s'est pas très crédible et on sait qu'à
la base il ya beaucoup de questions qui
ont été évoquées sur le sérieux de la
chine qui a peut-être tenté encore une
fois comme en 2012 de cacher l'arrivée
de ce nouveau coronavirus est ce que on
a raison de dire que la chine vient de
perdre plus que des plumes vient de
perdre son image et que c'est une c'est
une blessure qui va rester
oui parce que c'est plutôt de pouvoir
qui m'ont vraiment et manille de la
chine aujourd'hui on sent que ion un
retour du virus par des personnes qui
viennent de l'extérieur et de dire que
c'est un virus qui provient pas de la
chine c'est pour la consommation
domestique c'est pour la population
chinoise que le gouvernement veut dire
ça que c'est clair que les voisins de la
chine sont durement affectés
participants voix d'enfant dans le
gouvernement chinois n'est qu'à passer
du moins une difficulté gérer des
problèmes rapidement parce que cette loi
du silence parfois mines la transparence
des services sociaux en chine et
lorsqu'on parle justement dans une une
pandémie ou du moins une crise
importante a lancé l'ampleur que ça a
pris et on a tellement tardé
justement met en branle un processus de
report pour contenir sur le virus on met
beaucoup trop attendu ce pas ça qu'on a
dû mettre 56 millions de gens en
quarantaine ce qui est énorme et la
plupart des pays asiatiques sont
intimement intégré avec l'économie
chinoise
donc c'est tout les économies
avoisinantes qui en souffrent alors
c'est clair que l'on se pose des
questions sur la capacité du guarana
chinois à répondre à des crises
rapidement compte tenu de la
l'attitude de son système qui font en
sorte que dans le fond un angle mort et
fait que le gouvernement chinois perdu
d'enfants une capacité vraiment à
démontrer je voudrais son
professionnalisme alors c'est clair que
les gouvernements mais remettre en
question dans le fond la capacité de la
chine à répondre à ce genre de 10 est ce
que le fait monsieur régime maryse jobin
qu est ce qu on a fait du marketing du
côté du gouvernement chinois
avec six hôpitaux qu'on a construit en
dix jours en fait ce n'est pas vraiment
des hôpitaux
ça ressemblait davantage à dispose de
grands garages où on a tassé des manades
est-ce que je te juste de marketing pour
essayer de rassurer sa population
ha accueille dans contre des options à
dijon comme vous dites c'est bon il ya
une raison principale c'est justement de
contenir le virus est de mettre les
malades à l'intérieur de cette cet
hôpital
oui les balades était à à moins de deux
mètres les uns des autres
donc pour contre une propagation c'est
parce qu'ils aident mieux non une idée
de vendre la population chinoise un
gouvernement le groupe était très actif
et qu un gouvernement parallèle à la
crise en main et et on voulait dans le
fond on faire oublier que cette crise
émane d'un problème structurel en chine
avant c'est une façon dans le port on
peut pas dire qu'on a noté en référé
prévenir que guérir parce que là c'est
clair que je faisais gouvernement il
tentait de guérir d'enfants un problème
et les filles étaient sous jacent
dalphond à un problème administratif
pour se cacher que le gouvernement
chinois a avant tout comme bull parti
comme les chinois c'est ce que rappelle
l'harmonie alors c'est de démontrer dans
le fond que le gouvernement avait des
choses en main et c'est clair que c'est
pour rassurer la population chinoise qui
elle commençait vraiment à paniquer le
comprendre parce que ça donne quand même
affective
beaucoup de chinois dans leur vie
quotidienne et ça leur fait perdre aussi
beaucoup de temps des chinois de
l'argent alors c'est une façon d'en
pas de vendre dans le fond l'action du
gouvernement à sa population tout de
même tout de même on voit les
statistiques que la chute du nombre de
nouveaux cas depuis deux semaines en
chine
alors moi je me demandais ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait quelque chose au fond qui
a peut-être dans un sens au niveau d'une
grande démocratie comme le canada parce
qu'il ya des choses qu'on ne pourrait
pas imposer la population en raison des
lois sous lesquelles nous nous trouvons
mais est ce qu'il ya des choses qu'on
pourrait apprendre de la chine des
outils des façons d'intervenir qui au
plan de la santé par exemple ont un
certain sens ou non moi je vous dirais
que c'est plutôt le contraire
la chine va démonter ne fallait pas
faire c'est à dire que tenter de mettre
en quarantaine virus politiquement c'est
impossible tenté de censurer dans le
fond les lanceurs d'alert c'est toujours
possible mais on voit le dommage que
cela écrit alors dans le fond la chine
nous a démontré qu'il ne fallait pas
faire et c'est le problème intrinsèque
dans le fond de 10 régime de ce genre
c'est que lorsque les gens ont craint de
parler vaut mieux s'enterrer dans le
silence et là comme on peut voir un
virus lui le défi un peu de ces réalités
politiques et lorsqu'on aborde une
question de santé publique je crois que
là il faut vraiment tout démontré une
capacité à répondre à une crise plutôt
que de répondre dans le fond je m'en
prends à des relations publiques de
n'est pas le top
dans une crise importante alors les
chinois eux se sentent un peu découragé
peut-être aussi un peu déçus de leur
gouvernement qui n'a pas su dans la
fanfare abstraction de son dans le fond
de ses intérêts politiques et il ya de
cela plus d'enfants la crise s'aggrave
et qui se mène oui c'est ça monsieur
granger est ce que est ce que ça peut se
retourner contre la chine parce que
évidemment la chine est connue pour être
un régime qui surveille yuki
développe des technologies de
surveillance assez poussée même les plus
poussées au monde et pourtant bon comme
vous disiez le virus fait fi de toutes
ces programmes de surveillance politique
mais est ce que ce virus peut se
retourner contre le régime politique de
la chine
est ce que finalement la chine face à
ceux à sept organismes microscopiques
peut s'effondrer
malgré tout il va arriver par abraham
comme on m'a à plusieurs reprises une
partie de la population chinoise va
toujours mettre en doute d'enfants ce
que le gouvernement dit est ce que ça va
aussi brisé ou empêcher l'enfant la
chine de vendre son modèle socio
politique à d'autres pays du monde
probablement pas parce que à la sortie
de cette prise ils vont sûrement vente
et d'enfants les le succès du régiment
avoir contenu ce virus mais
fondamentalement leadership d'un crois
pas qu'ils vont être tellement ébranlé
contenu que on s'attend à ce que la
chine ne rebondisse de cette crise
le problème c'est que probablement les
relations extérieures de la chine avec
d'autres pays ont peut-être à en
souffrir contenu certains pays riches
qui vont avoir de plus en plus de
difficulté à faire confiance au front à
la chine alors je crois que
politiquement la chine va payer un pays
à l'extérieur de ses frontières mais se
plie sport relativement bénin à
l'intérieur est-ce que la dissidence
qu'on a vus comme par exemple le médecin
qui avait sonné l'alarmé au début de la
crise qui en est mort je crois est ce
que cette dissidence ça va changer les
relations entre le territoire de hong
kong annexée et ce qui se passe entre
les du niveau politique
oh je vous dirais que ça donne un outil
de plus au jeune homme caennais de ne
pas vouloir la réunification à la chine
pour démontrer que le régime qui ne
n'est pas transparent dans le fond peut
amener des grises et des épidémies
alors c'est un argument de plus pour la
jeunesse en carnet de nos pauvres à
réintégrer la chine et
il peut pas regarder tellement loin
parce que taiwan elle aussi va pouvoir
démontrer encore une fois que le système
politique chinois n'est pas adapté dans
le fond une nouvelle réel tic sont des
crises qui peuvent arriver très
soudainement alors favori en force et
dans le fond les le mouvement
indépendantiste taïwanais et le mouv
heures dans le fond non intégrationniste
des en cognant vers la chine et aussi la
chine est ce que j'avais ma question je
viens de l'oublier lemay a oui
économiquement on a vu que des images
incroyables de la nasa qui montrait une
activité économique versus wolfsburg
oui alors on a vu une absence de
pollution après la mise à quarantaine de
millions de personnes
est ce que comme ça la chine peut
survivre aussi à ça c'est à dire de
l'économiquement il y va y avoir à un
moment donné où cette puissance
économique avant des effets ou peut-être
qu'il ya déjà des effets sur l'économie
mondiale
comparé avec toi ça te coûter environ 50
milliards de dollars à la chine et ça
lui a pris cinq mois pour retrouver des
chiffres d'avant la crise
aujourd'hui c'est une crise qui est
beaucoup plus intense que le sras
falloir s'attendre que la reprise
économique est encore plus de contenu
que beaucoup plus dans le coin de pays
qui ont été affectés par ce qu'a fini
beaucoup plus intégrer économiquement en
2020 qu'en 2003 est aussi la différence
c'est que les chaînes de montage vous
savez aujourd'hui le cas des productions
sont faites sous dans plusieurs pays
alors ça l'affecté une beaucoup plus
grand nombre d'industries alors c'est
clair que dans le contenu économique la
chine va se relever mais ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps et je présume que il
va avoir une un rebond économique à la
sortie de la crise mais la chine
structurellement était déjà en perte de
vitesse depuis 1 heure au point de vue
économique c'est un peu normal peu
logique compte tenu que le taux de
croissance était tellement élevé à paris
live à la map invitez votre toujours
commencer à diminuer compte tenu du
vieillissement de la population chinoise
et d'une des industriels disent
on est à prévoir et qui évolue de la
part de pékin
parce que le volume à chinois devait
changer de modèle économique
c'est-à-dire délaissé dans le fond le
système industriels polluants avec la
marge de profit très faibles pour se
lancer dans une économie développée
alors là l'économie développer vos
nécessités de meilleur dans le fond
logis citer qu'un point de vue avant
faute de sa transparence alors la
question se pose de ce que la chaîne va
être capable dans le fond d'atteindre ou
de de percer dans le ponceau plafond de
verre qui plusieurs pays sont
nouvellement industrialisés mais ont
beaucoup de difficultés à atteindre une
économie développée lorsque est ce qui a
fait le succès de la chine c'est une
main d'oeuvre abondante et bon marché ce
n'est plus le cas les avantages
comparatifs d'un pays en voie de
développement ou disparus en chine
donc ça ça va on peut amplifier ou
rendre encore plus difficile sa sortie
d'enfants nos systèmes industriels
polluants alors dans le fond ce que veut
faire la chine
il va falloir qu'elle travaille encore
plus fort parce que dès le système
économique chinois est avant tout basé
beaucoup sur les exportations c'est
quand même une économie très mondialisé
la chine ses 56 % de son pib ici des
exportations et là on voit la crise dit
on de vie d'ailleurs par les neuf
satellites comme vous avez souligné
la chine exporte moins en ce moment donc
très clair quand mon ami un recul
économique important il faut s'attendre
mais je vous dirai pas à vendre la
défaite de voir retour à la normale
j'aimerais amener le canada dans tout ça
parce qu'on sait que
les relations étaient plutôt tendues
depuis décembre il ya un peu plus d'un
an en raison de l'arrestation de
certains personnages on va passer au
dessus de l'histoire rapidement vont ces
histoires des chicanes dispute est là
depuis début février on a vu les deux
pays à avoir des discours diplomatique
ma foi très sympathique au niveau de
l'amitié la canada via nous était le
canada n'est pas aussi réactionnaire que
les états unis ont apprécié la chanson
il est là est-ce que ça va durer est ce
que la chine a vraiment besoin nous
maintenant mon dieu ce serait incroyable
là c'est clair que pendant la crise le
ton non à la remise canada plc plaisir
la chine et le fait aussi qu'on n'a pas
empêché les ressortissants de chinois de
venir au canada faut aussi ça faisait
vraiment plaisir la chine et compte tenu
que nous avions comme l'avait souligné
beaucoup de problèmes reliés à faire
croire oui c'est un autre vision de
justement peut-être d'adoucir ses
tensions qui ont été créés avec
l'arrestation de manouane tôt alors vous
avez là dans le fond à l'occasion qui
fait le larron c'est à dire que on avait
besoin d'un élément ou d'un déclencheur
pour désamorcer leur conception
c'est pour ça que la balle était repris
au bond par les deux gouvernements parce
que les deux gouvernements voulaient
probablement d amorcer des relations
tendues alors l'attitude du canada était
une bonne façon d'enfants de renouer
avec un discours qui est un peu plus
représentatif du passé des relations
sino canadiennes qui ont depuis très
longtemps été jugée relativement saine
alors vous savez en chine lors que le
gouvernement chinois veut justement se
rapprocher d'un pays ou du moins la
presse chinoise par le soin bien soit en
mal du pays
parce que sadique dans le temps le désir
du gouvernement chinois alors le fic
dans la presse chinoise
l'action du canada était bien vu c'est
clairement un geste il pousse des deux
pays à se réconcilier
maryse mais je me demandais c sipa
canadien mais la visite de trump alors
qu'il y avait crise en chine c'était
stratégique
en inde pendant que la crise éclate et
en chine c'était stratégique pour dire
il n'ya pas seulement la chine avec qui
on peut faire des affaires
l'aide est très populeuse à une main
d'oeuvre
on peut aussi faire des affaires avec ce
pays même prédiction c'est à dire le
désindustrialisation de la chine vont se
diriger vers l'est vers le bangladesh
vers le cambodge
lorsque ces des pays qui peuvent vont
avoir l'avantagé comparatif d'une main
d'oeuvre abondante trop cher et aussi
c'est le secteur dans le secteur mou
c'est à dire des secteurs textile les
souliers les jouets des choses comme ça
à l'enfant la chine veut s'en départir
de toute façon il va perdre 200 millions
de travailleurs d'ici environ 40 ans
alors c'est gilles dans le fond seront
vides de travailleurs alors c'est un peu
normal qu'on va les délocaliser dans
cette région du monde mais la visite à
prop en aide
il ya plusieurs raisons qui expliquent
sa des sites premièrement avons une
raison politique parce qu'il n'a rennes
ramon audi est un peu comme donald trump
la façon qu'ils gouvernent donc les 2 et
2 les deux enfants cette pluie
mutuellement
il ya aussi oui cette question aussi
économique l'un va devenir une puissance
économique il faut le prévoir parce que
ce pays bas atteint 1,8 milliard
d'habitants elle va surpasser d'acino
20-27 est quand même étonnant et vous
avez aussi d'enfants si vous regardez à
très très très long terme qu'elles
paient le mieux positionné pour faire
contrepoids à la chine
il faut penser à l'un parce que c'est un
pays qui limitera pas de chine et qui
ont une certaine ascendance soit en asie
du sud-est et aussi des nouvelles
alliances qui ne crée avec le japon
maintenant je donne un exemple très
simple les etats-unis le japon
l'australie et l'inde mais n'a pas
partie de ce qu'on appelle le dialogue
kadri latéral et qu'est ce qu'ils ont
commencé quatre pays là c'est l'accueil
de la chine donc la visite de tom n'est
pas simplement conjoncturelle mais elle
est aussi structurel c'est qu'on voit
plus salon automnal fois au
rapprochement états unis pour faire
contrepoids à cette chaîne est aussi le
canada là dedans est-ce que trudeau
devra faire autre chose pour aussi
peut-être rebâtir un gip littoral
eckland
je vous dirais que la prochaine fois
qu'ils ne savent pas
non j'espère aussi que va avoir quelque
chose de concret dans les mains parce
que le dernier voyage clovis m'excuse
mais pas tellement grand chose à offrir
avec l'inde le canada aussi signé un
accord de promotion et de protection des
investissements avec la chine en 2013 et
on n'a toujours pas ça avec l'un quand
même surprenant parce qu'on a un système
légal qui est beaucoup plus proche
d'hélène qu'avec la chine
alors si on est capable de signer des
traités économique avec la chine
pourquoi ne le canada n'est pas capable
de le faire avec l'un n'allant c'est une
grosse déception ce voyage là parce que
moi je m'attendais sérieusement à skis
cet acteur un parce que ça c'est une
prime une discussion pour un libre
échange et je vous rappelle qu'en
novembre 2013 le gouvernement
conservateur avait promis une entente de
libre-échange avec l'inde
nous sommes en 2020 alors c'est clair
que vous avez l'eau dans le fond un
parent pauvre de la politique étrangère
canadienne c'est l'inde et ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans le combo punk
pousser davantage notre fonction
publique ou ministère des affaires
étrangères à se pencher ou du moins
investir plus sérieusement vers l'inde
elle n'a pas envoyé un premier ministre
les mains vides dans ce pays mais très
belle conclusion puis on vous écoute un
mot je me demandais si vous vous faites
payer 5 dollars aux gens qui veulent
assister à votre cour mais qui sont pas
inscrits officiellement c'est très
agréable vous écris faudrait lâcher un
gros merci beaucoup professeur granger
merci le plaisir c'était serge granger
libyen cité de sherbrooke un professeur
en politique appliquée on le sentait
qu'ils se réchauffer la wii la partie on
a le plus besoin d'arrêter rien fait
quand même une affaire malheureusement
pour lui de rencontrer des gens comme ça
virtuellement évidemment écoutez vous
êtes prêts pour la partie jeu deuxième
je démissionne
allons-y là soyons plus performants pour
cette deuxième phase vous allez tous les
deux perdu 3-0 carney
ouais c'est simple je soutiens bonne
paie 5 ans mais la mauvaise ou très
mauvaise voici la deuxième question
quelle est la couleur du cheval blanc de
napoléon aussi deuxième question il y a
dans le monde près de cent mille cas
confirmés de personnes atteintes par le
virus
combien de ces personnes sont jugées
maintenant guéries est-ce que c'est à
plus de 16000 est ce que c b plus de
30000 36000 j'espère ou est ce que c'est
c'est plus de cinquante six mille jeunes
rappeurs mais mon latin
elle vous avez quarante deux secondes
maintenant pour répondre à bombay où ses
fils on est ce qu'on fait durer le
plaisir où on donne valant je dirais
plus de cinquante six mille l'une cinq
ans si on y va
entre larmes à l'optimiste vous non
c'est énorme et justin chine quoi s'il
ya eu plein jour à oui c'est vrai parce
que 90 mille club
le problème maintenant par prenez le
temps pour elle à 10 h 56 min oui quoi
non se passe quelque chose c'est
inévitable sur la mer la can a d'abord
envoyé à l'est pour votre confiance pour
16h à l'ère du mobile
marie c'est selon moi je crois que c'est
être anti naylor je vais aller avec
ok alors maryse a finalement choisi de
rester avec son premier choix non elle
va avec bmi grandes villes et elle perd
36 mille dollars
c'était a pas de réponse cinquante six
mille ha ouais j'ai déjà dit que je
restais sur cinq
avez-vous dit merde en ont dit non mais
j'ai pas acheté des mots pires cas c'est
oui j'en suis sûr alors ces valeurs vous
avez perdu votre boule bio flore simat
amato du ch ont remixé l'émission à
vincennes
oui malheureusement écoutez mais au
niveau des cales sa grotte ces miels
sont sans appel qui sont maintenant jugé
guéri 7500 paraître le taux de mortalité
autour de 2 à 3 pour ça alors technique
mais ont cependant cette fois c'est quoi
le 6 1 96 mille personnes qui meurent et
ouais y'a peut-être 5 arte 6000 qui sont
remis là mais le reste va se remettre si
ce temps là la vérité c'est qu'on ne
sait pas c'est quoi le nom mentalité
c'est très compliqué il faut lui et il y
aurait beaucoup de gens voilà le déchet
qui meurent peut-être que c'est trop tôt
dans un an on va le savoir mais
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas ce qu'on sait
cependant c'est qu'elle soit 1100
personnes qui sont dans un état grave en
ce moment aujourd'hui la plus de 3400
personnes qui sont mortes et trois des
personnes en chaîne qui sont décédés 403
par exemple voilà c'est les bons
chiffres que la chine communiqué ce que
l'iran ce sont les bons chiffres que
l'iran comme une écurie pays ne sont pas
équipés de la même façon pour gérer la
crise et savoir combien il ya des gens
qui étaient vraiment affecté moi non
est-ce que vous avez le goût d'en savoir
plus toujours grâce à vous les
journalistes des animateurs du canada et
sociaux nous allons savoir plus voici
notre j'appelle ça pour en savoir plus
c'est moi confie t on pas d'imagination
surtout le dire ce que cette petite
vidéo quelques secondes seulement
vous allez voir c'est tous les articles
sérieux poursuivre sont pas seulement
les échos sur le cac vide ces jours
derniers et depuis les tout débuts donc
veut voir vous pouvez voir maintenant
comment les choses se sont révolus et
pour les canadiens c'est le point de vue
des canadiens là dessus puisque j'aime
beaucoup la temps c'est que chaque jour
par exemple à radio canada international
si vous vraiment savoir ce qui se passe
pour que de faire le tour des jeux c'est
pas de différents postes de services
internet à utiliser but recherché oui on
s'intéresse aux causes et 19 ont fait
qu'au vu de 19 dans le haut d'un outil
recherche et l'on peut consulter tous
les articles
souvent il ya des jours où la publier
4,5 en un temps afin mécanisée louis une
bonne couverture helmand parce que c'est
vraiment le sujet qui préoccupe tous les
canadiens en ce moment et puis là vous
voyez c'est d'autres émissions de il ya
quelques temps où on a hâte c'était le
30 janvier dernier
on s'est rendus aux laboratoires
québécois qui me disait juste d'observer
pour vérifier les russes n'avaient reçu
les affaires là c'est tout nouveau ça
donnait un outil de plus au québec pour
eux plutôt que d'envoyer des choses à
l'euro à winnipeg au laboratoire
national on envoyait sa québec pour que
ce soit un maintien de ses plus
rapidement c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
ben en fait depuis hier on dit qu'il ya
deux formes de corner virus oui j'ai vu
ça avant ce nouveau et que l'un des deux
serait plus mortel que l'autre ok alors
là sa course toutes sortes de problèmes
par rapport à où comment on va
développer un vaccin
si on en a deux et là il faut qu'on
développe des vaccins contre les deux
souches ça veut dire qu'un seul chemin
choisi temps
l'api portel probablement et on envoie
les ressources de ce côté là alors ça
pose tout un symbole il ya peut-être une
mutation du virus ce qui devenu un
traître lorsqu'on donne le vaccin de la
grippe
il faut pas faire une particularité du
lieu exactement alors que les bactéries
elles ça change pas et ne pousse pas
aller jusqu'à un autre expert exactement
intéressant nous ont fait poser des
questions pour l'instant les réponses si
les gens allaient coton des réponses
soyez gentils écrivez nous pour nous
pour que nous puissions ne pas d
informer mais plutôt en forme il est
question ben ouais pourrait aussi faire
réagir à ça écoutez je vois j'ai encore
le goût de rire un peu assez loin le
résident je sais quand je dis on traite
de sujets très sérieux à ces démissions
souvent c'est la job comme on dit au
québec mais notre travail est comme on
dit à radio canada c'est quand même de
faire le tour de tous et puis pour sa
part sa troisième grosse tour de la
boule quand mes boules à perdre 30
chalet perdu 50
j'ai toujours grande confusion ici puis
lui l'art est il beaucoup il ya 60 81 84
canet voici la question plaisir de tous
et chacun sait au troisième tour de la
grosse boule qu'on me touche pas si vous
lisez l'information ce qui se passe
quand vous travaillez vous me dites moi
comment les indices dow jones --le
performé hier
est-ce qu'il a perdu 3,6 pour cent ce
qu'il a gagné 1,3 pour ça est ce qu'il a
gagné 2 6% soit deux fois plus que le
signal akrofi ou est-ce qu'il a perdu 3%
quelle est la bonne réponse avez vous
savez vous ce qui s'est passé hier
audard jones
lorsque vous avez des actions à la
bourse à ce que vous surveillez ça à
tous les jours encore villareal a gagné
1,3 pour cent voudriez qu'il a gagné 1,3
pour cent un rebond peut-être vous
travaillez pour quelle firme
d'investissement alors il dit paix et la
gagner 1 la gueule
hélas 22 une seconde mais moi je dirais
qu'il a perdu 3,6 soit 16 pour faire la
peau par diers a pas de
3 3 ou 3 points 6 mai john jay avec le
plus gros comme terrain perdu ou gagné à
perdre j'ai perdu moyens ce qui s'est
passé hier
vous dites quoi gagner gagner vous y
trouvez mari a perdu et vous dites banda
ça va bien alors il ya eu des ducs a
perdu voilà hélas perdu 3,6 pour ça mais
il y avait une réponse qui est
intéressante c'est le 1,3 pour cent de
celui le d il a perdu 23% ça c'était
lundi 6 xx au canada toronto star parce
que je me souvenais d'avoir vu à la télé
le tsx
ils apprennent ils me servent aux états
unis là parce que beaucoup de cas le
fameux paquebot qu'on n'a pas voulu
laisser que bien sûr lacoste et en
californie
alors là je me suis dit les choses c'est
l'effet du corps on avait pensé comme il
y avait le big youth day aux états unis
ce mardi
oui mais les effets ça a eu un effet
apparemment de l'allemagne il paraît que
sa belle ça si hayden une lutte et
performant qui les investisseurs this
transpo pas et donne c'est la même chose
c'est tous ceux des riches qui vont
donner aux riches alors que sanders et
aura un effet voilà socialisant oui il
avait milliards chose qui va donner un
milliardaire jusqu'à je pense qu'il
n'est pas aussi riche que toi mais tu as
quand même temps il veut pas déclaré key
sauber concède moi vraiment bien
écarté de la course là non il est gardé
le malade il avait oui il avait dépensé
1,2 milliard de dollars au dessus des
100 millions il m'a envoyé un petit
million j'ai dit non je peux pas faire
de publicité rci les dés sont jetés et
que tu es comment on finit une émission
de belle manière
1 à part une autre une autre question
devinettes ouais c'est bon t'as pas de
boules c'est pas la mona lisa avec le
masque de bloc opératoire qui dit ah
quand même c'est pas la pesc donc si je
lis ça c'est pas ça c'est beaucoup plus
ludique
est ce que ces tremblements de terre de
montréal ces 3 2 3 3 le soir sur hermès
ça vaut même pas de mention sao voilà
vous savez qu'au québec a déjà eu des
problèmes internes pop veut avoir plus
gros que cela s'est passé
on est sur une faille et non mon canal
sinon il ya risque mais possible
important qu'est ce que vous devez faire
une émission la semaine prochaine sur
les risques réglementaires au canada on
va peut-être donner une réponse est le
sujet déjà alors c'est l'image de la
semaine je répond par oui ou par non à
lucknow à vos questions seulement par
oui ou par non et vous devez deviner
quelle est l'image cette semaine c'est
végétale minérale ou occidental je ne
sais pas on y va question j'attends
c'est écrit j'ai tellement ouais c'est
pas non c'est pas ça
cela se passe au canada
non ça se passera au canada l'impact sur
le canada oui c'est sûr tu n es pas
qu'au canada que c'est de la bouffe dame
ou le non politique
ben c'est ça fait partie tout petit peu
près 7 peu lié à la politique
certainement moins aux états unis non
pas aux états unis non ça non mais dans
un pays anglophone
ah oui et du commonwealth j'aime avec la
nacre en exil le nom s'est pas laissé
passer ça alors c'est fini ça olala
poser des questions c'est quoi ces
traités non pas de noter la très terne
et alors ça serait quoi sait déjà qu'ils
sont bien traités ils sont très bien
traités à la famille royale
oui oui un seul à partir de maintenant
ne reçoivent plus de sécurité mais ce
qui n'est pas payée par le gouvernement
canadien
voilà ils vont venir s'établir au canada
donc c'est pour ça que j'en parle
aujourd'hui puis l'image la semaine
c'est eux alors qu'ils sortent de leur
véhicule c'est en angleterre bien sûr à
londres et si vous allez comprendre
pourquoi ces images la semaine si vous
avez des problèmes avec l'épilepsie
cesser maintenant de regarder
voilà pourquoi ces images la salle
odyssée c'est la première sortie
officielle ensemble depuis qu'on sait
qu'ils ne feront plus partie des
obligations nous aurons pu a besoin de
faire ce que je dois faire un regard des
comme ça ça je pensais qu'il y avait un
problème avec mon fils confie d'idéaux
je sors très populaire c'est la grâce
c'est une des raisons pourquoi ils
veulent venir au caire c'est quoi un peu
éloigné des paparazzi anglais ben oui
regardez moi ça ici là on y verrait même
pas ce raid un noir complet
là bas on fait que les affiches et vous
a beaucoup racheter ses parts dans la
vie des gens riches et célèbres way
cet excès donc traiter ça à ça se peut à
l'époque il n'y avait pas internet et
regarder tout ce qui se passe à la télé
ouais bah il est trop jeune et sans
youtube on peut retrouver ces presque
tous les grands succès du pass dire
quand même acte et c'est tout pour cette
semaine j'espère vous avez apprécié le
ton de l'émission
malgré son sujet et c'est toujours un
plaisir de recevoir vos commentaires à
la fin de l'émission ou même au début où
pendant sur sur le web sur facebook
et sur youtube si les choses se sont
passées bleus techniquement à semaine
prochaine ismaël malige merci à la
semaine prochaine bye
[Musique]